coming up a striker with a difference he
plays here for borussia mentioned
gladbach and was one of the league's top
scorers in the first season half with
eight goals and six assists
max cruiser before last weekend kluse
hadn't scored in nine matches and
gladbach hadn't won
still the club's offense headed by cruza
and brazilian rafael is an example of
the modern style
but is cruza really a striker
or is he more of a midfielder who likes
to play forward
we asked him what it's like playing this
new brand of soccer yeah
i'd say i'm something in between that's
somewhat of a trend at the moment what's
known as the false nine it hasn't been
around very long but it's being
incorporated more and more by most or
many clubs you might say i'm the
prototype
um
that's exactly why i wanted to talk to
you so how would you classify yourself
personally i'd say i occupy both
positions i think that i'm a player who
has a certain overview and can make the
final pass
but i think i'm also able to convert the
ball i'm passing myself so it's a bit of
fun
have you tried out all the positions
goalkeeper for instance
no i've never been a goalie but i have
played a lot of positions i was left
back at bremen for a time but i was just
too attacking for that it's better if
i'm put forward in the first four
positions
we talk about all these concepts at the
office but it would be great to have
someone explain it who actually plays in
the position
even for us it's not so easy to explain
so where should i start yeah
let's say we play a classic 442 like
this
and
yeah i don't know and i'd say that the
false nine when i'm playing it moves
defensively as a number 10.
but i think we complement each other
well rafa and i we alternate
it's this flexibility that enables us to
both be able to play these positions
one of us always goes back to get the
ball and one always goes forward
the good thing is that one of us doesn't
always play forward
but that we change positions
and how do you work it out
it's training and communication during
the match
okay so it's spontaneous okay
sure
it's not as if one of us says i'll play
up front for this half it's based on the
situation and on which side the attack
is going
when it's on the left and i'm standing
here i'll usually go forward and rafa
will get the ball to separate our
opponents a little but flexibility's
vital when it comes to unsettling the
defense too
and that's also what the false nine is
about right changing position and
varying your role
so is there still a place for classical
strikers today
if you have what it takes you'll always
prevail
i'd say that the classical striker will
never die out
for me the best example right now is
robert lewandowski he's a classical
forward with all that goes with that he
has good ball handling skills he's good
in the air and is technically sharp but
it always depends on the club and the
players it has so what's it like when
you're the named striker and aren't
scoring goals
i don't think about it too much
if you work hard at it you have the
talent and have shown that your luck
will return i'm trying to do that for
much of my career i've relied solely on
my talent now i'm where i always wanted
to be
but staying here requires a certain
discipline and ambition this is a very
important phase in my career and i'm
doing everything possible to realize my
dreams
reality